el congreso de perú otorgó su voto de
confianza al nuevo gabinete de pedro
castillo los legisladores votaron 68 a
favor 56 en contra con una abstención
castillo dio la bienvenida a la decisión
con el voto de confianza otorgado por el
congreso seguiremos bregando sin
descanso por los cambios que el pueblo
necesita somos el gobierno que impulsa
la gesta de la reivindicación social y
que apuesta por el desarrollo de
nuestras regiones con unidad y consensos
lo haremos
la jornada de evidenció la atención
política en el país así como su división
ante el congreso simpatizantes de
castillo demandaban la disolución del
parlamento
[Música]
y cerca al lugar detractores del
oficialismo pedían un juicio político
para el mandatario
y
horas antes castillo había tomado el
juramento al exfiscal avelino guillen
como nuevo ministro del interior-
guillén es conocido por ser uno de los
fiscales que llevó al expresidente
alberto fujimori a la cárcel debido a
violaciones de los derechos humanos el
ejecutivo tuvo que reformarse después de
que el ex ministro del interior
renunciara tras conocerse que había
organizado una fiesta de hallowen a
pesar de las estrictas medidas impuestas
por el gobierno contra la pandemia es el
segundo gabinete del mandatario en 100
días en el cargo